let us bring you a Georgia Congressman
buddy Carter Congressman great to have
you on the program now that the court
has thrown President Biden and his
administration a Lifeline a Lifeline
that he fought against mind you what's
he going to do with it
well hopefully we're going to enforce it
and he will be uh he he will be calls to
enforce it and and that's a good thing
look if it weren't for title 42 we'd
have a full-blanc catastrophe at the
southern border right now we've already
seen they were they were preparing for
it whenever it was to expire I applaud
the Supreme Court for what they've done
if they had not done this that I hate to
think of what would be happening at that
southern border right now I've been to
the Border unlike this President and and
I've seen firsthand I've talked to the
Border agents who by the way are doing
yeoman's work they're doing humanitarian
work and they're doing an outstanding
job but that's not what they were
trained for that's not what they're
there for they're not being able to to
use their skills of enforcement because
this Administration is hampering them is
hindering them from doing just that this
Administration has got to wake up and
they've got to do something about this
this this disaster that we have right
now at the southern border while all
this is happening president president of
the United States has a nice fruity
drink with an umbrella in it here soon
to be colleague Florida Congressman
elect Corey Mills says Joe Biden's
vacation is really par for the course
from this White House listen
this almost appears to be the status quo
of the Biden Administration whether it's
Biden going to the Caribbean during a
time of this Cyclone bomb in our open
Borders or whether it was Pete budajag
during our supply chain issues who went
ahead and went on leave instead of
addressing the issues for Department of
Transportation so the real problem here
is that they don't want to address the
issue they're playing political football
to kick it down the line
so Congressman that's the White House
and obviously they've had two years to
deal with this they haven't I don't
think they will going forward but that
remains yet to be seen once you as the
Republicans take the majority in the
house literally next week are you
prepared to work with Senate Democrats
who have the majority over there in
their body to come up with a bipartisan
solution that works for the American
people and stops this horrific problem
at our border
absolutely we're ready we're prepared
and we're going to do just that let me
tell you uh you know oversight is one of
the strongest tools we have in our tool
chest and we're going to use that we've
got to make sure that this is being
taken care of I I would submit to you
that in many ways a divided government
works better I mean you only have to
look to the to the recent past with Tip
O'Neill and Ronald Reagan with uh Newt
Gingrich and Bill Clinton to see when
where they got things done and I'm
looking forward to this because you know
this this one-party Democratic majority
rule has obviously not worked now that
we're going to have control of the House
Representatives we're going to bring
bipartisan bipartisan solutions to get
some things done and certainly the
border is one of the most pressing
issues if not the most pressing issues
that we have to deal with right now in
this country for so many reasons not the
least of which is the fentanyl
continuing to enter our country across
the border at record levels because of
that the FDA is now fast tracking their
review of a new over-the-counter drug
for opioid overdoses overdoses I should
say Congressman are we reaching the
point where literally every home and
every business in America is going to
need to have Narcan or one of these
devices these drugs to counteract the
effect of Fentanyl
we are reaching that point the Narcan is
becoming almost as as common as
defibrillators are and and that and I
plot the FDA for what they're doing
because they take the unprecedented step
of going ahead and and and and
formulating
OTC
um packaging and labeling for Narcan
even though it hasn't been approved and
Congress and the FDA has been
encouraging the pharmaceutical
manufacturers to apply for the OTC
status of a Narcan and that's what needs
to happen right now you know when it
first started talking about this I used
to say well there's enough illegal
Fitness on this country now to kill
every American seven times over as time
has gone on that number has grown to
there's enough illicit fitting on this
country to kill every American 10 times
over it's increasing that much we've got
to do something about this epidemic this
poisoning of our citizens by fentanyl
that's coming across that border when
will this administer situation wake up
when would they understand that this is
a national epidemic that we have going
on here right it's like multiple Terror
attacks every single day and the
administration does nothing about it
Congressman buddy Carter you're doing
something about it thank you very much